right now if you were to make a list of
the top 25 things that you could do in
your business that you are not doing the
obvious things that you know would make
you more money if I emailed more I'd
make more if I did more reach outs I
make more money if I made more content I
make more money if I train my sales team
more if I did more call reviews I'd make
more money if I reorganized our customer
onboarding process if I created a better
Cadence or training for our customer
support team or customer success team we
need to make more money put out every
single one of the obvious bullets that
you had that you know would grow your
business instead of doing the new thing
do those all right spiritually difficult
as an entrepreneur because we like to do
new [ __ ] it's why we started the
business to begin with we stopped doing
the old thing we started the new thing
and we got reinforcing that behavior we
learned the wrong lesson we learned that
when we start new things good things
happen but now if you start another
thing you will get punished